welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 13. after
this there's only three episodes left in
part two of the final season and things
are heating up the best way to watch is
on amc plus so click the link in the
description to sign up and join in now
this episode starts off at hilltop with
elijah remember maggie's super cool
mysterious masked ninja friend but he
doesn't wear his mask anymore so he's
kind of just a normal cool dude lydia
has decided she's had enough of roughing
it out here she's gonna go to the
commonwealth and elijah turns out has a
crush on her but just then someone rides
up on a horse and oh he's been shot as
he dies he has them a map like hey come
help us our gang figures if this guy
found hilltop someone they know must
have sent him here so maggie elijah and
lydia go on a road trip lydia's like yo
maggie why did you not accept the
commonwealth's help maggie tells a story
of how before the zombie apocalypse
living on her father herschel's farm a
big corporation wanted to buy him out
and try to give him supplies during a
drought but herschel turned it down
cause it's like hey you know then they
would own us maggie never wants to be
beholden to anyone else she would rather
barely get by but be self-reliant then
they run into some commonwealth soldiers
but oh they're walking like zombies yeah
these guys died and coming up behind him
who's that it's their friend aaron now
we go back a week to see aaron visiting
the commonwealth at a church where
father gabriel's preaching earlier he
basically given up on his faith but now
that he's safe in the commonwealth he's
like you know i like god again aaron is
still mostly living in alexandria but
he's gotten a job at the commonwealth
with their department of reaching out to
other groups and bringing them in what
he was originally doing back for
alexandria his boss carlton is all hyped
up to bring in this new group they found
of about 40 people living in this
apartment complex and they bring father
gabriel with them because apparently
it's a religious group but this
apartment complex seems well fortified
and not friendly to strangers it's like
yo i think this is a bad idea but
they're still going in and indeed these
people don't seem friendly and this
apartment complex is a dark and scary
place they could really use some more
natural light their leader here is just
a random tough guy and he does not like
visitors it's like yo man you don't have
to live like this anymore we got the
commonwealth it's a nice happy place but
he doesn't trust him he's got a whole
shelf full of skulls of people he's
killed and he's gonna add theirs
carlton's a scared little wimp but aaron
manages to talk this guy down he's gonna
let him go but wait what's this surprise
attack from carlton he's not a wimp at
all he's a master assassin turns out
this is actually a secret mission
authorized by lance hornsby a
commonwealth caravan was ambushed
recently and a bunch of weapons stolen
apparently by this group and carlton in
his past was apparently a master
assassin so it's like hey man i need you
to go in there kill them all and get the
weapons back so now he's interrogating
this guy where are the guns you stole
but he's not saying so carlton kills him
and it's like yeah sorry aaron and
gabriel for not telling you but we're
not bringing this group in we're killing
them the intern they brought apparently
feels bad about this and tries to escape
so they're shooting him but oh aaron
steps in and attacks a stormtrooper
aaron's in big trouble now so he runs
away and also inside somehow father
gabriel escaped too turns out as this
intern was fleeing who did he run into
but negan apparently after negan left
our group he met up with the apartment
people and now when he hears this guy
with metal arm and a priest it's like oh
okay those are my friends so he's the
one who told this kid how to get to
hilltop and it's like ask maggie for
help the negan stunt inside and rescued
father gabriel who was pretty surprised
to see him here and now they're all
holed up in various apartments while
upstairs the interrogations continue and
oh carlton kicking people off the roof
he went from i don't kill people anymore
to full psychopath real quick so the
remaining apartment people prepare to
fight back and now they've got
reinforcements from maggie and friends
we're building to an intense climax here
now's the time to join in and the best
way to watch new episodes of the walking
dead is on amc plus stream each new
episode a week early and be the first to
find out how it all goes down how is the
standoff going to end who will live and
who will not will aaron and gabriel be
able to rejoin the commonwealth or will
they be fugitives for good and what
about negan what is he doing where's he
gonna end up you gotta watch these last
few episodes of part two of the walking
dead's epic three-part final season so
click that link in the description and
sign up for amc plus now
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]